julian brandt spielt gegen timo werner
nicht auf dem fußballfeld sondern in
fortnight die teamkollegen royce stindl
klostermann waldschmidt stark und hart
sind auch mit dabei auf der mashup
competition in köln spielt der großteil
der fußball-nationalmannschaft entweder
vor ort oder über das netz zugeschaltet
zusammen mit sportlern spitzenfußballer
und leistungssportler die videospiele
spielen kein widerspruch sondern längst
selbstverständlichkeit
jeder hat ja mittlerweile heute in
seinem haushalt ps4 und xbox ich glaube
dass das sind wir ja mittlerweile in der
zeit angekommen wo das gang und gäbe es
und es macht riesenspaß ist ein super
ausgleich natürlich auch verkaufen ja
natürlich kommt es auch schon ins
schwitzen weil ja eigentlich situativ
schnell denken muss es ist ähnlich quasi
wie man fußball kennt wurde schnell
handeln muss das charity event wird über
die streaming plattform twitter
übertragen knapp 280.000 euro gehen nun
an die toni kroos stiftung sos
kinderdorf und die sports total stiftung
aber es soll auch ein statement sein für
den export denn da werde genauso hart
trainiert ist auch sehr zeitintensiv ist
es halt kein körperlicher sport aber ich
bin schon so seit meiner kindheit
eigentlich täglich stundenlang videos
spiele natürlich hat ja keine auszeiten
und so aber das ist wirklich sehr viel
arbeit und
leidenschaft die man darin stecken muss
um gut zu werden wenn man sich mit dem
thema mal ein bisschen mehr befassung
gerade dass ich mit 12 sportlern auch so
ein bisschen unterhält was da alles drin
steckt dann merkt man dass natürlich die
körperliche belastung ist bei uns
deutlich höher das ist klar aber gerade
vom kopf her ist das enorm was die jungs
da treiben und auch die fußball profis
konnten die sportler überzeugen die
nationalelf kann auch fortnight